verse 33 what does shirako gone
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you're not going to regret this are you
[Music]
with that the contract is final she say
artery
no difficulty breathing is there
very well then let's go I've heard
rumors but I've never actually seen one
all these creatures not human or animal
but something else I've seen plenty of
unusual things I guess I shouldn't be
surprised it doesn't matter I just want
some place I can call home and now for
the item you've all been waiting for
a rarity even among our current
offerings will open at 500,000 1.1
million 2.25 I have two million two
hundred and fifty thousand going once
going twice
excuse me five million
it's decided you will be my apprentice
who is he what the hell do you think
he's up to I'm not sure
prepare a reception room wait you have
agreed to the price of five million
pounds he spent a fortune of team who is
money like that she's docile so she
shouldn't give you any trouble it was an
unexpected honor to see you at the
auction however we must ask that you
follow the same rules as everyone else
including staying off the stage
I'm not here for a small talk or a
lecture you come no need to keep your
head down back straight chin lifted eyes
forward
understood yes I'll be borrowing your
Lobby by all means
he's some kind of monster careful what
you say you wouldn't want him to hear
you he is neither a con artist nor an
alchemist
he's the genuine article a rarity these
days a shame can't believe we allowed
him to win it the slay Peggy's his slay
baby so you can see them excellent where
you speaking to me do you see anyone
else here I might have been speaking to
what's your name it's juicy
my name is cheesy hitori my name is
Elias Elias Ainsworth pleasure to meet
you my little puppy
from what I've observed so far it
appears that you have the sight how
fortunate fortunate take her even think
of the expense what would people think
if we gave her to an orphanage though
well perhaps someday we will be able to
change that some people may appreciate
your passivity but I am NOT one of them
I paid good money for you I didn't come
here looking for a doll carry yourself
like somebody who is worth looking at
Hey
now close your eyes and stand close to
me you may feel a bit dizzy
nettle in the shadows false Holi in a
ring twine the branches entangled in
mesh spin a spider's web
you can open your eyes now as I expected
we made it in one leaving welcome this
is my home and as of today it is yours
as well wait hold on I'm confused
where are we how did we get here from
the auction house where to the west of
London in the countryside on the
outskirts of England we're in England
now and what am I an apprentice of oh
yeah you won't be needing that anymore
as of today you are my pupil an
apprentice mage a mage there's no way
we're a dying breed and I warn you you
may find me a bit old-fashioned I
welcome you into my home as my new
apprentice slave eggy no she say
[Music]
no way I can do it myself I know how to
take a bath but do you know how to use
this tub besides your feel feet
I'll help immerse yourself completely or
you'll take a chill you saw everything
come out when you've warmed up this is
nice I wasn't sure I would ever get to
take a real bath again you know if
you're so eager to throw your life away
perhaps you should consider giving it to
someone who would make better use of it
than you can
I smell something delicious what an
adorable little human girl are you
fairies well fairies of the term you
humans always seem intent on using for
our kind there are so many butter names
you could use those sweetie that's right
you should call us your neighbors or
your good friends
hey you're asleep at your chew taking a
sleigh Becky for an apprentice
that's silly foreign-made sometimes I
wonder what he's thinking do you think
sweet as honey wine we're valuable than
a treasure chest more precious than the
most beautiful berry flower adorable
adorable our dainty little Robin if
you're going to become a major he'll
give you all the help you need we're
happy to look out for you beloved just
say the word yes I am fine I swear it's
all under control please you don't need
to come in here they're gone
have some food and drink I imagine it's
been a long day he's going to a lot of
trouble to make me feel welcome you look
like you have a great many questions in
lieu of a bedtime story ask and I shall
do my best to answer there were fairies
in the bathroom those were the Ariel's
I'm not surprised they greeted you there
a track to do anything new and shiny
their aerials and is it true what you
had said before about you being a mage
yes it's true
[Music]
and when you say apprentice
I mean apprentice my little puppy slay
begi are exceedingly rare I was very
lucky to find you
I hadn't heard that term before today
what is asleep eggy the best comparison
I can think of is a queen be you or
rather your kind slave eggy have the
unique ability to attract and bind all
manner of things specifically Fae
creatures think of Fae beings as worker
bees they are drawn to their queen
whether she can see them or not not all
Queens see them it appears you have that
ability but it is not a common one among
your kind nor is it necessarily a
blessing they bring ill luck as often as
good luck what they may intend as
kindness and generosity does not always
translate as such in the human world
however to be favored by them means you
will never be without assistance you
need their aid in order to perform magic
so their attraction to you is not
without its benefits you may not think
it now when I suspect you will become a
great mage someday that said I won't
force you down a path you don't wish to
take i'm bought and paid for are you
telling me I can do whatever I want now
well no however you may think things
over
becoming a mage is just one of many
possible paths as my apprentice you're
like family to me now which means you
can depend on me I'm family this is an
Adderstone the whole eroded naturally at
the bottom of a river it will help to
protect you wear it always
come here silver you must be tired why
don't you turn in now would you please
show her to her room
first a hot bath and now my own bedroom
family huh what is that scent it almost
smells like grass
you're the fit
oh I mean you're the neighbour hello
again care for a midnight stroll there's
a lovely voice nearby I don't know oh
come on it'll be fine we'll just go out
for a little bit a good walk will wear
you out and you'll sleep much better
let's get going
[Music]
what a foolish child still it will make
for a good lesson it's like the air is
filled with sparkles
that's the trance before you tell me
about your family I don't have one I was
passed around by different relatives
like were they kind to you she finds not
the word I would use I don't think I
would be here now if I've been able to
love them hey we come a pretty long way
haven't we don't worry your pretty
little head about it let's keep going it
won't be a problem after all you weren't
going to be returning to him anyway five
minutes to pull one over on the thorn
age wait what are you saying I take you
back to our land sweet Robin the others
will be terribly cross with me if I do
oh don't look so nervous it'll be crazy
a lot easier than living in the human
world the ways even open through here
lies the fairy Kingdom a world of
freedom you'll like it I promise
wait hold on
No I'm going back back where exactly
it's not like you have a family waiting
for you she's right I don't have anybody
[Applause]
hey what's the matter I can't do it I
can't I have to go home nonsense
you're being silly what possible reason
could you have to go back to that house
in my whole life nobody has ever made me
feel like I was welcome but that's
exactly what he did
maybe I'm just a plaything maybe he'll
get bored and toss me out and even so
for one day he made me part of his
family so ah excellent
it looks like my puppy has already
learned where her den is
you came to me how did you know where we
were
none difficult when her collar has a
bell on it be gone I'll forgive you this
once next time you'll be either meat
seafood sure I can and I will she say we
learned a good lesson tonight didn't we
Fae creatures are fond of seducing
humans with sweet words and pretty
promises I'm sure you'll be more careful
in the future I I'm sorry no I should
have warned you about their tactics
straight off after all it's my duty to
guide and inform you whenever possible
as my apprentice you should be able to
depend on me for such things he's so
warm but am i imagining it or does he
seem a little tense
Hey what are you doing it's easy to get
lost in the forest I'll carry you now
let's go home
we'll need the patch of your arm when we
get to the house I wouldn't want my
future wife to end up with nasty scars
what's that about a wife Oh haven't I
said I told you earlier that I purchased
you to be my apprentice and that's still
true but you should know I also hope to
make you my bride
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
a girl departs for London with a
powerful mage unfamiliar town's
unfamiliar people the world offers a
kind hand to a lonely child will that be
all
shall we begin preparing for our
honeymoon
[Music]